hey guys it's Matt from the score
eSports before capturing a league season
two and winning the major Taric was no
shirt TV
tarek is known for his entertaining and
sometimes bizarre personality but he had
quite the reputation for questionable
decision-making giving him the nickname
peanut brain this is bad this is
terrible what we're doing it's fine
science fine
I'm button spray transfer
why doesn't only not end dude these days
tarik is proving all the haters wrong
has used plowing through the competition
with cloud nine
from his early whimsical career to the
highs of winning a major here is the
best return looks like they're gonna be
purchasing even more from the other side
he's gonna get the one killer that's a
good job but I don't think it'll be
anything else you follow so don't taste
it on easy how is he not dead yet a low
on the other side
teri hatcher you've got to be kidding
you catch up four kills
that's impossible how does he wear all
in six they're trailing and it's pistols
here
that spray transfer so sick be bombs
like me mother first up in support base
good deed in the first few don't take it
out Terrans gotta go huge it he's gonna
crossfire with Rush we've got Guardian
in the short position and he's exposed
but he goes down rushed their life for
persons three supporting one plane maybe
tweets or just position that wasn't
short but and yet don't you brush my
teeth when they're on the pistols is not
hard he's gonna find just one more
anymore because it's huge as he finds a
third takes down Scott goes oh really
the best chance of self is here is to
try and find where there's n we've been
playing and take them out but they just
be going for a good old be Russians did
and he go actually getting caught out of
but not even find out with his players
were and that's how he look to do it
well three finds three tarik now I
showed on the jumping Slammy then tarik
with the four main here the ice to get
the north skirt the Molotov is good but
Eric when is he gonna swing the bolts
August actually has not spread that far
and completely coming from cloud nine is
it my neck never heard from playing now
with the support I'm getting from this
dxracer that you can find at the
expiration calm code coupon code not
cloud9 effort zero percent off wait it's
max Dominic I gotta go
actually looking both ways right now
he's gonna miss the shot but Stan's
going down care be picking up to massive
kills and Kerrigan taking our mix well
that's all on Terry he's gonna get one
kill and now open the box down to us he
doesn't have a kid picked up and
Kerrigan's right on the other side with
the m4 if he misses a shot here
good boy a jumpin has to run and pick up
the kid and folks back over does he get
it I think he is gonna get it just in
time it's gonna be so close but it looks
like they playing the object
that's automatic down as heavy fines the
rotations this Russian Tara Cooke at
this there we go
but I can't get the third one now as
well as he takes down KNG penny now all
of a sudden is the last man standing
Tarek makes an amazing player they shut
it down and give it to the cloud nine
beautifully played by Derrick fixed
effect there's a flashbang up there's
the kill there's the fall drop as well
Terry gets aggressive finds one more
rush drops down it's the wrong moment
Tarek swings out water gets another that
leaves cold syrup one buses - missed
opportunity there jumps science paid off
the shot at Erika's then come sing it
out with a quark he'll put the smoke
down to try and allow he and Tarek to
get much closer to breeding to act
quickly he's gonna get behind the mother
flank
because he's gotten automatic down and
infuse Paul Dirac Erik's got it cloud9
got it before they could actually get
him inside of the smoke unbelievable
right clicks the flashes of the three
second mark and the T's got completely
wrecked by it it was a four on two I
think at that point and look there they
have no chance in it whatsoever the 4d
piece is happening right now that
flashbang goes off tarik saves the day
four players alive very play look what's
wrong
[Music]
I don't know about that oh my god I'm
trippin bro
I'm not even on object row what am i
doing what am i doing bro oh my [ __ ]
god I can't believe I just did that
oh my god I did one as well so now half
this prong of this attack is shut down
and that's a fake tactic for Tarek Turks
in the perfect spot he's gonna swing out
there completely blind it's free kills
for Tarek all three get mowed down nice
defense by Tarek since the absolute
beginning of his team Kerrigan leaving a
Stronach turret as well he's got lots of
fruit and he's trying to do so
relentless aggressive doesn't matter
what the situation oh that's thirsty but
it is Front Street IPE Tarek fishes
swims up he popping up the tec-9s came
in rushing against them obviously it's
still a bit of an issue but it'll be in
a good position good molotov means they
can't get that close to him as well
Tarek now it's gonna be up to bat here
to pick up the first couple of kills
fighting to color and smugly picking up
two more unlikely sell they just read
that perfectly that could run down Terry
give you misses a single kill here they
could definitely just close the distance
and he's immediately gonna fall back
passing up behind him they're still
right on his tail and Terry now trying
for the noscope skidoo look there oh my
god Terry still staying alive how did he
do that here we go uh-oh
did he get a cut by 1 2 3 and set for
that now I actually talked to you a
little bit a little bit about this right
before this interview and you had
mentioned that Peter really took over
with the in-game calling ever since
earlier this year and gradually over
there we have seen that you guys have
been steadily improving and showing them
an impressive performance especially
recently now he's gonna push for into
the smoke the flanker coming up behind
him isn't gonna catch him now he's
looking for that to be a flash but look
holy crap
let's see he's gotta find the 14 seconds
left on the clock and he's gonna again
hold back on the Sisqo to win this round
he's got his hold back now he can't get
too aggressive though because if he
pushes this too heavily you can still
take him out he goes
don't go down without a fight
Oh Tarek's not either he's jumping up
shotgun comes through mag-7 shot into
the face of ominous ii won him over
that's go for the reload the
black-themed awkward but I love it but
they're just gonna push through the
smoke here and coos - eats a nade he's
gonna go try to go for the peak in Tara
she's gonna get caught out but he spins
he gets the shot gets the second to
third you can take me what his doing on
Terok 1v2 is hiding inside the pool with
the p250 Tarek looking to put this round
away first running out of time you
chasing down Terry don't let him have it
look at the angle of his keyboard this
is mad 90-degree angle and that mad 90
degree angle and has allowed him to get
really important frags
why is your keyboard tilt it like that
well after my first night event we kept
winning just couldn't lose I felt sorry
for my opponents so viewing the chance
myself a challenge more importantly I
started tilting my keyboard this game's
way too easy otherwise wouldn't be fair
they've added stun into the leadership
role they don't let by no means a Polish
but hang on a second because it looks
like tarik is providing us quite some
polish play himself it's seventy four
out of five nice mows them down teaches
us how to count to five one
and with one Health's pad just for some
style points
I can see just yet so with the boost
could play that how this shot it seen us
on the find a flag in that situation but
there you go it's our final five now we
can see that people pissed around here
Tarek gotta get a good head shot in and
you spotted a lot of other people he's
already got the information that is a
real a push there's no fake into this
here's another one takes out a scene
that is gonna be going to Albert Terry
he can't be stopped he's looking for
more it's gonna get the quad kill but go
believe it Eric brah a hero and now
cloud - awarded a fight Canton with your
fatal only good for the one kill the
Guardian is also here what is there
can't find an angle there has to
reposition the bomb goes down and while
the slight long hours players get into
position the CT rotation begins to come
in and they look ways from every single
angle right now for different points of
attack potentially Guardian he's gonna
give us a buck that time in position to
exploit his plays through the smoke
character undiscovered where's the
refract olofmeister not close enough to
deal the damage an automatic can reset
the situation is tarik waits patiently
[Applause]
there's the peak that l8 bex is there
he's just baiting he's baiting for shops
there goes Kenny and it's a good trade
somehow okay
the job oh my god he swapped out the a K
to continue that fight through the smoke
test territory take you down and beat
and it's all on body one versus three
he's already got the first kill the band
will go down and now once again outlying
can just fall back and play this one see
he has the real quick he has to make
this work body pushing into the side
goes for the fight he's gonna take one
kill he has no idea what eric is and
he's gonna get shut down quad kill here
horse hair and picking up the seventh
round for cloud nine do this before but
this time he's been discovered tackle
take him down as the five before the
cloud farmer forty seconds ago in
Kerrigan he can't reposition he has the
frag he asked a frag and he gets only
one position he managed to get there
fast enough the bomb has to be pointed
in car line at a disadvantage
tarek brave enough to just hold the
bombs lon
he knows Guardians and construction
trying to back off trying to reposition
sees him tag him but doesn't frag him
holding the angle once again but as you
go hide as you go low
it is a dance and now they concede
multiple ankle terrico he takes on a
five-star down
Guardian on deliver HP reigned at peaks
and he gets the angle now superior angle
is there it is use for the CT sights and
on in just yet this family grenades
they're touching the pot and now go
frame another Bob that is trend
has taken down absolutely unreal rock
drop line and the Storify thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]